If you got 10 over 21, you got it right. Let's see how to get that answer. Since
these numbers are large, we want to try to factor them before we multiply them,
and see if we can cancel any factors. So, we can write 8 as, 4 times 2 and we
can write 15 as, 3 times 5. For the second fraction, we can write 25 as 5 times
5. And we can write 28 as 7 times 4. If you notice, there's a 4 in the
numerator, and a 4 in the denominator. So, we know that 4 over 4 equals 1. Also,
there's a 5 in the numerator and a 5 in the denominator and we know that 5 over
5 is equal to 1. So, after we cancel any factors that are in common between the
numerator and the denominator, we simply multiply the numerators together, so
we're left with 2 times 5 and we multiply the denominators together, 3 times 7.
So we know, 2 times 5 is 10, and we know that 3 times 7 is 21.